Squeezie - Et bien bonjour les amis j'espère que vous allez bien, aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour une vidéo avec
les deux zigotos.
Bigflo - Surprise les amis !
Squeezie - On sait pas qui vous êtes. Vous avez des masques en fait. Attention !
Oli - Hey !
Squeezie - Ah mais c'est Bigflo et Oli !
*Aplaudissements*
Squeezie - Attendez, attendez, attendez !
Squeezie - J'aimerais déjà remercier le maître, le maître Alain Rey
Squeezie - Qui dans la précédente vidéo nous a vraiment porté bonheur, nous a apporté beaucoup de choses.
Squeezie - Il nous a donné la force de diriger les mots
Bigflo - Alain, guide nous vers la lumière.
Alain, grâce à la force ...
Oli - Ohlolo !
*Rires*
Squeezie - Il a craqué, il en avait marre.
Squeezie - Bon les mecs, vous savez comment ça se passe ? Etape une, on la connait bien maintenant !
Squeezie - Alors les gars, j'ai eu une idée d'un beat. Alors ça fait :
Squeezie - *Mélodie*
Squeezie - Enfin à peu près ...
*Rires*
Squeezie - Attend la dernière fois t'as tout à fait compris le message !
Bigflo - Allez, bon allez. Je vais me débrouiller avec ça !
*Mélodie*
Bigflo - Bah voilà !
Squeezie - Alors, à quel moment ?
Squeezie - A quel moment, c'est pas ce que j'ai fait quand j'ai chantonné.
Bigflo - C'est grâce à qui ça à votre avis ? C'est grâce à qui qu'on a ce pouvoir ?
Squeezie - Etape deux, je la rappelle ?
*Beat Kick/Snare*
Bigflo - Accélère pas !
Squeezie - Ah bah t'es musicien ou pas ?
Bigflo - Vas-y on l'enregistre.
Squeezie - T'as fais le conservatoire ou pas ?
Bigflo - On l'enregistre et c'est toi qui le fait.
Bigflo - Un, deux, trois
Oli - Stop les gars
Squeezie - Il nous a coupé ...
Oli - Vous aurez remarqué que je fais toujours rien dans cette vidéo.
*Rires*
*Beat Snare/Kick*
Bigflo - Ohhhhhhhhh !
Squeezie - Est-ce que je suis officiellement musicien ?
Bigflo - Très très chaud !
Bigflo - On écoute les deux, les uns sur les autres ?
Squeezie - Allez !
*Mélodie*
Oli - Elle marche bien déjà comme ça hein !
Squeezie - Elle est pas mal la déjà.
Bigflo - Merci c'est fini pour moi ! A plus les gars, bonne vidéo !
Squeezie - A bientôt
Squeezie - Bon alors, je vais chercher, Ah !
Bigflo - Trois et !
*Beat Basse*
Oli - T'es pas obligé de chanter en même temps mais ...
* Beat Basse*
Bigflo - Ohhhh !
*Applaudissements*
Bigflo - Eh franchement il va finir par faire un album lui !
Oli - Etape quatre les fio
Squeezie - ri
Bigflo - tures !
Squeezie - Et non pas la con-fi
Oli - ture !
*Rires*
Squeezie - Ok les mecs, vous savez que récemment je suis allé au Japon.
Bigflo - Pour aller chercher un chien.
Squeezie - Ah tu connais bien ma vie !
Squeezie - Bref les mecs tout ça pour dire que j'aimerais qu'il y ait des petits instruments qui nous rappellent
Squeezie - finalement l'ambiance asiatique, l'ambiance japonaise !
*Mélodie*
Oli - Kon it shu hi uj ni tshu on inh chu
*Rires*
Squeezie - C'est hyper raciste !
Oli - C'est pas raciste les gars...
*Rires*
Squeezie - C'est archi raciste !
Oli - Oh nan putain mais nan
Oli - Gros big up à tous les asiatiques !
Squeezie - OK !
*Mélodie Ambiance Japonaise*
Bigflo - Oh et franchement c'est lourd !
Squeezie - C'est lourd PUTAIINNN !
Squeezie - Les amis il est maintenant temps de passer à l'étape préférée de la planète à savoir écouter l'instru
Squeezie - avec tous les sons
*Musique*
Oli/Bigflo/Squeezie - Yo, yo c'est la partie deux
Squeezie - Si t'aime bien Alain Rey tu peux lacher un gros un pouce bleu !
Oli/Bigflo/- Ohh !!!!
Squeezie - *Rires*
Oli - J'en profite pour vous dire que vous pouvez voter pour nous, pour les NRJ MUSIC AWARDS
Squeezie - Attend vous êtes en train de faire quoi là ?
Bigflo - On fait de la pub ouais.
Squeezie - Pourquoi y'a les NRJ MUSIC AWARDS qui arrivent là ?
Oli - Yeahh !
Squeezie - Bon les mecs j'arrive.
Bigflo - Juste, pendant que Squeezie il est pas là, il faut avouer que sa chaîne elle est pas ouf !
Bigflo - En vrai mais on fait des vidéos comme ça avec lui mais en vrai c'est pas ouf du tout.
Oli - Pas ouf !
Bigflo - En vrai nous ce qu'on voulait c'est faire des vidéos avec Cyprien mais bon Cyprien il a ...
Oli - Après il est cool tu vois Squeezie on peut pas, tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
Bigflo - Il est cool vite fais, pendant les vidéos il est cool mais en vrai il nous parle même pas entre les prises quoi
Bigflo - En vrai ...
Oli - C'est long par contre là ! Il est allé le chercher ou son dico ?
Bigflo - C'est méga lent !
Squeezie - Ok les amis je suis en train d'aller chercher Alain Rey, pour surprendre Bigflo et Oli.
Squeezie - Il attendait le pauvre depuis un moment en bas, je vais aller, le chercher et c'est lui qui va nous donner les mots !
Squeezie - Ok c'était plus long que prévu désolé. On est bon !
Squeezie - Ok, attend moi ici là.
Oli - Tu sais ce que je venais de penser là ?
Squeezie - De quoi ?
Oli - Je me suis dis il nous préparait une surprise.
Squeezie - Nan mais les mecs !
Oli - Y'a Alain Rey qu'arrive ou quoi ...
Bigflo - Pourquoi il est reparti ? Le mec il nous donne le dico il est reparti ! Cette vidéo on va la faire seuls en fait.
*Rires*
Bigflo - Mais nan mais c'est vrai !
Oli - Mais c'est énorme !
Squeezie - Les amis je vous présente Monsieur Rey !
Oli - Enchanté Monsieur, enchanté ça va ?
Bigflo - Putain c'est un truc de fou !
*Rires*
Oli - Monsieur c'est un honneur de vous rencontrer, on s'est renseignés sur vous on en parlait tout à l'heure avec Lucas.
Bigflo - On est hyper émus de vous voir.
Oli - C'est un truc de fou !
Bigflo - Et il viens de le dire en plus on a dit "Et imagine il y a Alain Rey qui arrive".
Squeezie - Et les mecs c'est chose faite je voulais vous mettre bien aujourd'hui.
Alain - Merci à vous d'avoir dit "Comme Alain Rey, Comme Alain Rey" !
*Rires*
Squeezie - Alain tu peux peut-être en dire un peu plus sur toi, sur ce que tu fais.
Oli - Oui voilà !
Bigflo - Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire "diriger les mots" ?
Alain - Si vous voulez y'en a des millions on les connais pas tous parce que
Squeezie - Moi j'avoue je les connais tous. Mais après franchement si vous les connaissez pas tous il y a pas de problème.
Alain - Il les connait pas tous !
*Rires*
Alain - Moi mon boulot c'est d'essayer de refléter un petit peu ce qu'il se passe à l'intérieur d'une société
Alain - qui emploie une langue comme le français. C'est vachement compliqué parce que, ça bouge sans cesse.
Alain - Au moins, deux, trois mille mots, expressions et sens nouveaux tous les ans.
Alain - Donc, il s'agit pas de choisir n'importe quoi mais on choisit ce qui est le plus courant
Oli - Franchement, je trouve ça hyper cool Alain de votre part, de venir jouer le jeu.
Squeezie - J'ai demandé à Alain avant de venir je lui ai donné une petite mission.
Oli - Ah c'est Alain qui va choisir les mots.
Squeezie - C'est Alain qui à déjà séléctionné des mots, pour nous les gars.
Alain - J'ai pris des mots simples et compliqués à la fois. Simples car ils sont faciles à prononcer.
Alain - Compliqués parce que personne connait leur sens, sauf lui parce qu'il connait tout.
*Rires*
Squeezie - 5 mots chacun, on commence par Oli.
Squeezie - Premier mot.
Alain - Cubilot
Squeezie - Cubilot
Alain - c u b i l o t
Squeezie - Alors c'est quoi cubilot, qu'est-ce que ça peut être ?
Bigflo - Cubilot moi je vois ça comme un espèce de coquillage.
*Rires*
Squeezie - Ok dit nous Alain.
Alain - Cubilot c'est un fourneau en scidérurgie. C'est là qu'on fait fondre la fonte.
Squeezie - OK.
Squeezie - Note bien hein ! C'est pas un coquillage ...
*Rires*
Alain - Deuxième mot, épissoir.
Squeezie - Attend j'ai une théorie je peux la partager ?
Squeezie - Le pissoir c'est la ou on pisse. L'épicerie c'est là ou on achète les épices. L'épissoir c'est l'épicerie dans laquelle on pisse (nope)
*Applaudisements*
Squeezie - Merci à tous !
Oli - C'est l'endroit ou on met les épices tout simplement ?
Alain - Nan nan, c'est ...  Vous pouvez pas prévoir (rekt')
*Rires*
Squeezie - Il nous a calmé Alain.
Bigflo - C'est le boss qui est là !
Alain - Ca vient d'un verbe épisser, avec deux "s". Episser c'est quand on assemble en marine les marins
Alain - connaissent, c'est deux gros câbles il faut obligatoirement l'ouvrir, faire sortir les petits torons, et
Alain - associer les torons les uns aux autres.
Alain - Et l'épissoir c'est le poinçon dont on se sert pour séparer les éléments à l'intérieur du câble pour pouvoir les ...
Oli - Ok.
Squeezie - Whoaaaouh !!!!
Squeezie - Eh mais les gars, c'est la deuxième vidéo y'a plus de challenge.
Bigflo - Là le challenge il est élévé
Squeezie - Alain il va pas nous choisir des mots comme "philosophie".
Alain - Je cherche à vous faire chier ...
Squeezie - Ah bah voilà *rires*
Alain - Le troisième mot "chibouk".
*Rires*
Bigflo - Chibouk c'est un pokémon avec des cornes un espèce de bouc ça évolue en "Chichibouk" et en troisième évolution c'est "Chichibouki".
Squeezie - Putain mec, j'y croit.
Et alors la vraie définition ?
Alain - C'est une pipe orientale avec un grand tuyau.
Oli - C'est l'ancêtre de la Chicha quoi ?
Alain - Flober en parle beaucoup quand il est ...
Bigflo - Ah oui je l'avais lu ça ! J'avais lu "Je fume donc mon chibouk, posé sur le mont Ouk" ...
*Rires*
Squeezie - Qu'est-ce tu raconte ?
Alain - Quatrième mot, ça c'est dur. épectase...
Squeezie - Uh ! Moi je dirais c'est une maladie corporelle tu sais, "l'épectase".
Squeezie - Je pense c'est quand tu branche un truc et que tu prends un coup de jus.
Alain - C'est pire qu'une maladie.
Squeezie - C'est pire qu'une maladie ? Ah merde !
Alain - C'est le fait de passer l'arma gauche, de crever, en baisant.
.
..
...
*RIRES*
Squeezie - Ok, cette vidéo est géniale.
Squeezie - Woaw !
Alain - Ca veut dire que quand on est vieux il faut se méfier. *rires*
Squeezie - Cinquème mot, Alain.
Alain - La "merzlota".
Squeezie - Merzlota
Alain - C'est pris aux russes pour vous diriger.
Oli - Merzlota en fait c'est dans la tradition russe. Comme la mère poule tu vois c'est une mère qui prend soin de ses enfants.
Oli - On dit "Ah t'as vu elle c'est vraiment un merzlota !".
*Rires*
Alain - Alors c'est le sol quand il reste gelé toute l'année en profondeur.
Bigflo - Par contre celui-la pour le placer il est dur.
Squeezie - Ok.
Premier mot pour Bigflo
Alain - Un mot facile dans la vie vous allez peut être le connaitre c'est "cryptogame".
Bigflo - C'est toute la gamme des cryptos qui existent.
*Rires*
Alain - Un cryptogame, c'est tout simplement un champignon.
Squeezie - Biensûr !
Alain - C'est la famille motanique dans lequel il y a notamment les champignons.
Squeezie - Alors, deuxième mot pour Bigflo.
Alain - Deuxième mot, qui est évidement trompeur c'est "conoïde".
Bigflo - C'est tout ce qui est, tu vois y'a sinusoïde, machinïde. Donc c'est qui a une forme conique
Alain - Alors, c'est bien il a trouvé.
Squeezie - C'est ça ?!
*Rires*
Squeezie - Alors là ! Là je vais te dire, il y'a 1000 personnes qui viennent d'acheter l'album.
Alain - Alors là, vraiment un mot à la con. "pétéchie"
Squeezie - Pétéchie ??
*Rires*
Alain - Nom féminin.
Bigflo - Une pétéchie.
Squeezie - Une pétéchie.
Alain - C'est une tâche sur la peau qui ne correspond pas à une cicatrice ni à une blessure. Comme tous les vieux
Alain - mecs comme moi ça fait des fleurs de cimetière.
Squeezie - Mais respecte toi Alain !
Squeezie - Alors quatrième mot pour Bigflo alors.
Alain - Nictation. C'est le clignement des yeux quand il est pas contrôlé.
Squeezie - Ca va Bigflo ? Tu le sens bien ce couplet ?
Bigflo - Je le sens pas !
Squeezie - L'instru n'attend que toi !
Alain - Y'en a un qui doit être très très beau dans un rap c'est "épiploon".
Squeezie - Epiploon ? Ok je me lève.
Bigflo - Attend je sais même pas ce que c'est épiploon.
Squeezie - Bah tu tappe sur Google.
Bigflo - Nan mais j'aurais des images dégueulasses !
Alain - Oui c'est assez dégueulasse.
*Rires*
Alain - C'est un replis du péritoine entre l'estomac et le colon transverse
Squeezie - AHHHHH !!!
Squeezie - Ok. A moi Alain.
Alain - Bon je vais te mettre un mot féminin pour commencer, c'est très gentil c'est la "cucule".
Squeezie - Oh j'aime bien, j'aime bien, c'est à dire que mon couplet est tout de suite ridicule.
Alain - Alors la cucule c'est le capuchon des moines.
Squeezie - D'accord, ok.
Alain - Alors comme je sais que tu aimes les chiens, "chihuahua"
Bigflo - C'est gentil, il y'a du favoritisme là !
Alain - Troisième mot le "trombidion".
Squeezie - Le trombidion ?!
Alain - C'est un petit insecte, en fait c'est un acarien, c'est un piqueur. Un insecte piqueur de merde.
Squeezie - De merde ?
*Rires*
Alain - Quatrième mot la "logopédie".
Squeezie - Alors c'est quoi déjà ?
Alain - C'est en fait un peu la même chose que l'orthophonie.
Alain - Mais orthophonie tout le monde connait donc.
Squeezie - D'accord, ok.
Squeezie - Dernier mot pour moi.
Alain - "catachrèse".
Squeezie - catac ... wow !
Alain - C'est une figure de rétorique c'est à dire que ça ressemble à une comparaison ou à une métaphore.
Bigflo - Une catachrèse ?
Squeezie - Ah ouais ok.
Bigflo - Je maîtrise les métaphores et les catachrèses !
Squeezie - Alors les gars, j'aimerais qu'on propose un truc à Alain.
Squeezie - Est-ce que nous on te donnerait pas 5 mots, pour que toi tu fasses un Slam.
Alain - Je veux bien essayer ...
Bigflo - YES, IL EST CHAUD !
Squeezie - Alain, c'est quand tu veux !
Alain - ♪ J'veux pas mourir d'inanition, d'inanition ♪
♪ Mais j'veux chiller, chiller avec mes kheys ! ♪
Alain - ♪ J'aime pas trop les hipsters, j'préfère ceux qui me disent, oh mon khey, t'es l'sang, t'es l'sang! ♪
Alain - ♪ Ca, c'est peut être pas du freestyle, mais j'crois que ça fera le job, ça fera le job ! ♪
OHHHHH !!!!
Squeezie - Génial
Oli - Il a placé tous les mots.
Squeezie - Il a tout placé, il a même ...
Mais Alain !
Squeezie - Alain t'es le sang ! Vraiment.
Bigflo - J'arrive pas à croire ce qui viens de se passer.
Squeezie - Merci à toi venant de toute ma communautée et leur communautée.
Squeezie - Les gens vont vraiment apprécier.
Bigflo - C'était énorme !
Squeezie - Merci beaucoup !
Alain - Peut être qu'on aura d'autres occasions de se revoir.
Squeezie - Déjà ils t'inviteront à leur concert
Bigflo/Oli - Bah oui allez ! Si l'album vous plaît on vous invitera avec plaisir !
Alain - On va se faire un livre à quatre !
Squeezie - Ah, si vous voulez faire un livre pour aider les gens.
Bigflo - Ce serait trop classe.
Oli - Alain on garde l'idée hein.
Squeezie - Alain il est parti en moonwalk.
Bigflo - Sans même qu'on lui dise aurevoir.
Bigflo - Il a drop the mic'.
Squeezie - Bon les amis c'est là ou on annonce une triste nouvelle. C'est que vous n'aurez pas nos couplets aujourd'hui. A tous les trois, mais c'est pour votre bien. Parce qu'on va faire un clip.
Squeezie - Et ça sortira demain à 18H.
Squeezie - Ce sera pas un clip de malade parce qu'on a que 24 heures pour le faire finalement et l'organiser mais on va essayer de faire un truc bien.
Demain rendez-vous à 18H pour le street clip freestyle Alain Rey 2, à bientôt !
Sous-titrage par Jules Morel
Merci Alain Rey, Squeezie, Bigflo et Oli pour cette vidéo.
Passez une bonne journée !